bonjour à tous aujourd'hui à l'occasion
des championnats du monde d'athlétisme
qui sont terminées il ya quelques jours
je voudrais vous parler du fameux record
du monde du saut à la perche
alors quand j'étais môme je comprenais
pas pourquoi les perchistes prenez pas
tout simplement des perches plus longue
celle ci prenne une perche de 8 mètres
il devrait bien être capable de se
débrouiller pour sauter 8 mètres avec et
ben non en fait pas du tout aujourd'hui
on va voir pourquoi au saut à la perche
comme dans d'autres disciplines
d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout la taille
de la perche qui compte
la manière la plus simple d'analyser la
physique du saut à la perche c'est de
penser à l'énergie si vous voulez vous
élevez d'une certaine hauteur vous avez
besoin d'énergie pour vaincre la
pesanteur et il existe une formule qui
permet de calculer l'énergie dont vous
avez besoin cette formule c'est m fois
j'ai foi h ou h c'est la hauteur à
laquelle vous voulez vous élevez mc
votre masse et j'essaie l'accélération
de la pesanteur vous savez le 9,8 net
par seconde carré quant à perchiste veut
sauter à une certaine hauteur il a donc
besoin d'énergie et où est ce qui va la
trouver cette énergie et ben ils la
trouvent principalement dans sa course
d'élan
parce que quand on se déplace à une
certaine vitesse on a de l'énergie c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'énergie cinétique et
là aussi il ya une formule qui permet de
calculer l'énergie cinétique qui est
très simple c'est un demi 2ème fois vkr
et donc baisser la vitesse du perchiste
mc et sa masse donc pour calculer
l'énergie cinétique dont dispose un
perchiste grâce à sa course d'élan il
faut connaître sa vitesse
alors je connais pas exactement la
vitesse de pointe d'un perchiste mais en
gros on sait qu'un sprinter court le 100
m en à peu près 10 secondes donc 100 m
en 10 secondes ça fait une vitesse
moyenne de 10 mètres par seconde
évidemment un sprinteur va avoir une
vitesse de pointe plus élevé que ça mais
d'un autre côté les perchistes sont pas
non plus des sprinteurs et puis ils
doivent se trimballer la perche
donc on peut faire l'hypothèse que un
perchiste en vitesse de pointe
il est en gros à dix mètres par seconde
alors si on met ça dans notre formule
dix mètres par seconde et qu'on suppose
que le perchiste fait mettons 80 kg on
trouve une énergie cinétique de 4000
joule
maintenant la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est avec cette énergie cinétique
jusqu'à quelle hauteur le perchiste peut
espérer monter lorsque on va supposer
c'est qu'il ya absolument aucune perte
d'énergie c'est dire que toute cette
énergie cinétique
elle est utilisée pour s'élever donc si
on met quatre mille joule dans la
formule ème fois j'ai foi h et qu'on
suppose toujours que notre perchiste
fait 80 kg on trouve une hauteur de 5
mètres 10 ha oui que c'est pas mal du
tout puisque cinq mètres 10 c'est le bon
ordre de grandeur des sceaux qui arrive
à faire les perchistes avait quand même
un petit problème dans ce raisonnement
c'est que je vous ai dit ça c'est si on
suppose qu'il ya absolument aucune perte
d'énergie donc c'est en quelque sorte le
saut parfait on trouve cinq mètres 10 et
on sait aujourd'hui que le record du
monde
il est à plus de 6 mètres donc qu'est ce
qui se passe en fait la raison c'est que
les perchistes ne sont pas ponctuelle
c'est pas des points s'ils sont
certaines
il est donc le raisonnement convient de
tenir il s'applique au centre de gravité
et pour un être humain qui se tient
debout le centre de gravité il est à
environ un mètre du sol donc grâce à
l'énergie cinétique
le perchiste peut élever son centre de
gravité et de 5 mètres 10 et donc si le
centre de gravité est à un mètre du sol
ça fait 6 m 10 et là vous voyez qu'on
est quasiment au niveau du record du
monde du saut à la perche alors il ya
quand même un élément qui est très
important dans cette affaire c'est que
au moment où le perchiste passe la barre
il a un mouvement d'enroulement et ce
mouvement no roulement il permet en fait
que le centre de gravité du perchiste
passe au niveau de la barre voire
légèrement en dessous c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas besoin que le centre de gravité
du perchiste passe un mètre au dessus de
la barre c'est assez analogue à ce qu'on
trouve en saut en hauteur vous savez en
saut en hauteur le saut en fosbury est
beaucoup plus efficace que le saut en
ciseau est la raison pour ça c'est que
sur un saut en ciseau vous êtes obligés
de faire passer votre centre de gravité
plusieurs dizaines de centimètres au
dessus du fil alors qu'avec un saut en
fosse brille en fait le centre de
gravité passe juste au niveau du fils
voire légèrement en dessous donc élever
son centre de gravité de 5 mètres disent
ça suffit pour passer six mètres 10
alors à ça il faudrait rajouter quelques
petits détails comme par exemple le fait
qu un perchiste peut se donner un tout
petit supplément d'énergie en poussant
sur ses bras sur la perche au dernier
moment etc
mais c'est quand même remarquable qu
avec juste quelques considérations de
physique générale on arrive à retrouver
presque à 10 centimètres près la valeur
du record du monde du saut à la perche
alors quand même dans cette histoire
pour l'instant je ne vous ai toujours
pas parler de perche je vous ai juste
fait des raisonnements basé sur
l'énergie
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle fait la perche
dans cette histoire pour comprendre on
peut revenir au cas du saut en hauteur
classique
le raisonnement je vous ai tenu on
pourrait imaginer qui s'applique aussi
au saut en hauteur on a une certaine
quantité d'énergie cinétique et on s'en
sert pour s'élever dans les airs sauf
que vous voyez que ça marche pas du tout
puisque le record du monde de saut en
hauteur il n'est pas du tout à 6 m il
est à deux mètres 45
c'est à peu près la hauteur d'un filet
de volley ball ou bien d'un but de foot
alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'au saut en
hauteur on n'arrive pas à atteindre des
hauteurs aussi élevé qu'au saut à la
perche et ben c'est le fait que il ya
plein de perte d'énergie c'est-à-dire
qu'on estime que l'énergie cinétique
il y en a à peu près seulement entre un
tiers et un quart qui est utilisé pour
s'élever en hauteur c'est pour ça que
les gens qui font du saut en hauteur
arrive à élever leur centre de gravité
de seulement un peu plus d'un mètre
alors que les perchistes arrive à élever
leur centre de gravité de plus de 5
mètres pour comprendre pourquoi la
perche et la technique du saut à la
perche sont si efficaces par rapport au
saut en hauteur classique on peut
imaginer ce que serait le saut en
hauteur si on utilisait en plus à un
petit trampoline ou alors un tremplin de
gymnastique etc on placerait à la fin la
course d'élan alors je connais pas votre
record personnel au saut en hauteur mais
je suis quasiment persuadée que vous
l'explosion si on vous mettait un petit
tremplin de ce genre alors pour quelle
raison parce qu'a priori un tremplin
comme ça ça crée pas d'énergie eh ben
c'est tout simplement qu'un tremplin de
ce genre où un trampoline permettent de
bien mieux convertir l'énergie cinétique
de votre course d'élan en énergie pour
pouvoir vous élever alors comment ça se
passe
en fait si vous sauter sur un trampoline
à la fin de votre course d'élan il ya un
moment donné vous vous n'avez plus
d'énergie et vous avez tout donné au
trampoline c'est à dire que au moment où
vous êtes le plus bas dans le trampoline
vous êtes quasiment immobile donc vous
avez plus d'énergie cinétique
par contre le trampoline lui il est
complètement tendu donc il a accumulé
toute cette énergie sous forme de ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie élastique et
ensuite quand le trampoline va se
détendre et ben il va vous rendre cette
énergie mais d'une manière plus
verticale donc qui vous arrange plus
pour ensuite vous vous élevez dans les
airs donc le trampoline permet de bien
mieux convertir l'énergie cinétique de
la course d'élan et bien une perche ça
fait exactement le même
aux au saut à la perche et ça le fait de
manière quasiment parfaite c'est à dire
qu'à la fin de la course d'élan le
perchiste plan de sa perche et vous
savez il ya un moment donné ou le
perchiste et quasiment immobile par
contre la perche
ll est complètement tordus ça veut dire
qu'il a cédé à la perche toute l'énergie
de sa course d'élan la perche a accumulé
cette énergie sous forme d'énergie
élastique du fait qu'elle est plié et
ensuite la perche va se détendre et va
rendre aux perchistes cette énergie mais
cette fois dans la direction verticale
et ça va lui permettre de s'élever dans
les airs et la technique de saut à la
perche et la structure des perches sont
tellement bien optimisé qu'aujourd'hui
ils permettent de faire ça de manière
quasiment parfaite c'est à dire
quasiment toute l'énergie cinétique de
la course d'élan et transférés dans
l'attention de la perche et ensuite la
perche restitue cette énergie de manière
quasiment parfaite aux perchistes dans
la direction verticale lui permet de
s'élever et donc de passer la barre et
donc ce qu'on voit c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les saut à la perche sont quasiment
parfait du point de vue de l'énergie et
donc la hauteur atteinte elle est
quasiment aux limites de ce que permet
la physique
ça veut dire que il est assez peu
probable qu'un jour le record du saut à
la perche soit complètement explosé à
dire que même si demain quelqu'un arrive
avec une nouvelle perche fait dans un
matériau extraordinaire etc ou que
quelqu'un invente une nouvelle technique
de saut complètement révolutionnaire
comme ce qui s'était passé avec le
fausse berry en saut en hauteur et ben
ça améliorera peut être un petit peu le
record mais ça va pas améliorer le
record de 40 cm parce qu on est déjà
aujourd'hui aux limites de ce que la
physique peut faire et le saut à la
perche et déjà un saut quasiment parfait
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à comme d'habitude à la
partager pour m'aider à faire connaître
la chaîne
merci infiniment à tous les types heures
qui me soutiennent sur tipi sachez que
vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur
facebook sur twitter et aussi sur mon
blog qui s'appelle science étonnante
merci et à bientôt